record high 50 of americans rate u.s
moral values as poor okay so this kind
of goes to where you were going and
where i was going watch this
50 say moral values is poor 37 say only
fair 78 think moral values in the us are
getting
worse consideration of others cited as
the top problem with state moral values
we've been talking about this on the
podcast for the longest time we no
longer talk about morals and values one
of the whether you're a christian or a
catholic or a jehovah or seven day or
lds whatever it is the basic foundation
of judaism the basic foundation of any
of these religions is what forgiveness
is like kindness
don't judge
you know steal
all of this stuff is the basic
foundation of these morals and values
right
if we don't teach these basic morals and
values none of us will forgive none of
us will talk about redemption none of us
will believe in that i think this is the
problem america has today when 9 11
happened nobody cared about your skin
color we all became americans when covet
happens everybody hated the orange man
and everybody became enemies because it
was your political party before your
country this validates every point that
we talk about on this on this uh what do
you call it on this podcast here
schools
i can't tell you how many parents i'm
talking about where
we had one of our friends we were just
talking on public school what happened
to their kid they're like i can't send
my kid back to this public school i just
i'm not comfortable why do you know
what's the number one reason why they
can't send their kids back to their
public school morals and value do you
know why people are doing homeschooling
morals and values do you know why kids
are people are sending their kids to
private schools morals and values do you
know why church attendance on some
churches is at a record-breaking high
right now where people coming back
because people are starting to realize
if they're not going to give it to me at
my school i'm going to put it on morals
and values do you know why the football
coach that is known as raising great men
that strong values and principles do you
know why some parents are getting out of
his way or her way to challenge the kids
to become better human beings because he
or she is setting the tone with the kids
of injecting the right morals and values
do you know why certain companies with
ceos and executives are starting to
recruit talent that are coming to them
saying listen i'm here because of morals
and values this topic right here no one
is talking about because this is boring
nothing about this is exciting nothing
about this gets people to say oh yeah
let's go this is going to go viral let's
talk about this on cnn or fog let's talk
about this nobody wants to hear this
because this is a boring but necessary
topic
all of us
like
we don't like it but all of us
internally when we look back and we
think about a leader or a coach
that pissed us off the most or a
relative
it was typically a person that expected
more from us and we were like man i can
never get to that level but you know
that's the person you remember you
remember the worst and you remember the
person that pissed you off because they
expected more from you it was kind of
like i can never reach this guy's level
totally get it but you know what at 42
you're sitting there saying hey listen
you know what i'm missing claire kind of
love you man appreciate you thank you i
am who i am because you challenged you
go back to that right anyways what do
you think about this jet of that well
one of the things that i think broke
this for a lot of us was technology um
if you i think social media
and hiding behind phones and not having
eye contact and not having real
interpersonal relationships i think it
broke people hide behind if you look at
social media people say things on
twitter they would never say to you they
would never say to your face so i think
the rise of all of this technology and
and putting distance between people and
lack of community one of the reasons i
think that 911 and coveted were
different because after covid everybody
was isolated they were all separated you
became the enemy you over there oh you
i'm in my house and i'm staying home and
you're not staying home you're the enemy
oh i got a vaccine and you didn't get a
vaccine you're the if people where that
didn't happen was in places like florida
where people were out and about and they
were talking to each other and you
realized you had a shared humanity you
talked to somebody and you said oh
that's not my enemy that's just somebody
that made a different life decision than
i did
so that that's the difference i think
technology is number one and i think big
media is the other problem
big media i always say division is a
business model in big media and i think
they thrive they thrive off of screaming
and yelling oh let's put two people on a
screen split screen and have them yell
at each other but we're not gonna solve
anything we're just gonna we're just
gonna present this view that they can't
stand each other and that trickles out
so i think that that that's the part
about how we don't see each other as
people anymore which is why when when we
sat here with nikki freedom we had a
discussion people were like where is
this well it's not happening because
people don't do this anymore because
cable news doesn't thrive on it and
social media doesn't thrive on it so you
have to find and make those spaces
that's number one i think the morals
are a little bit that's
when you when you dig deep into schools
and what's going on that's going to
become a different conversation about
woke ideology and all that but the very
fabric of like i'm a human you're a
human we can disagree i respect you you
respect me let's hash it out that is
increasingly vanishing and you have to
think are our kids who only know a world
where all these phones are out and
social media are they going to grow up
able to have these conversations or are
they going to have lost that completely
skip that step because they don't have a
basis of comparison we had how many
years in the world before i didn't have
a cell phone until i was 19. i had a
normal functional childhood these kids
in an ipad and a cell phone we did on
the show this week virtual this and
virtual that and metaverse screw the
metaverse you your kid wants to play
send them outside send them in the
universe really
honestly get them ready
put that on a shirt by the way i'm gonna
i'm gonna do something right now that uh
jack carlo be careful he's coming adam
sauce here's what i'm going to do to
jedidiah right now
slow clap because everything you just
said i literally wrote down as like a
talking point that i wanted to discuss i
swear to god social media all your notes
okay community i'm like i'm joking bingo
why can't we get back to when we're
copying each other's notes in person
like we all did in high school we all
cheated
but
um you know there was a famous quote by
jfk asking out what your country can do
for you ask what you can do for your
country we've lost that
that sentiment of community and country
and you know the other side is the enemy
you know i'll never forget you talked
about social media i'll never forget
when i started my show sales talks money
i went around i was interviewing all
types of people and one of the most
lasting
conversations i had was out in l.a at
venice beach kind of right where we were
a couple weeks ago
and uh it was like this kind of like
cholo gangster type of guy mexican guy
and i'm like so what's going on with in
america with the money is like the
problem is everyone's so selfish and a
selfie is all about yourself
i was like oh damn
and i was like oh like a selfie is
you're more concerned with yourself that
i was like okay go ahead buddy he was
like yeah selfies are ruining the
contract values so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
you